stratford-uneven district council is
currently consulting on a site
allocations plan
this short video explains policy sap 7
in the preferred options
site allocations plan which relates to
the identification of built up area
boundaries
basically boundaries have been drawn
around the existing extent of the
built-up areas
of towns and villages in the district
which are deemed large enough to be
classified as sustainable locations
for additional development over the
planned period
the purpose of a build superior boundary
is to distinguish between land inside a
settlement where new development is
acceptable in principle
from land outside of settlement where
development is generally not acceptable
except for some exemptions which relate
to appropriate development in the
countryside
these settlement boundaries therefore
help to prevent development encroaching
into the countryside
the boundaries include and exclude
certain types of land
the full list of land types can be found
annex 4 of the site allocations plan
but in effect land included with placed
dwellings and commercial properties and
their immediate curses
land excluded from a boundary relates to
land on the edge of a settlement that is
undeveloped
such as playing fields allotments
paddocks agricultural land
and other non-domestic and
non-commercial type uses
each boundary extends around the
periphery of the settlement
areas of open land located within the
settlements have not been removed from
the boundaries
they are located within the main body of
the settlement and as such
remain within the built-up area boundary
itself even though open land within the
boundary
may not be suitable for development due
to its immunity
recreation or other value
in some instances not every single
dwelling on the periphery of a
settlement will be included within the
boundary
for that settlement this is due to the
existence of non-domestic
and non-commercial land parcels lying
between the edge of a settlement and the
dwelling in question
however dwellings which sit outside a
boundary remain part of the settlement
and will maintain the same planning
rights of those properties located
within the boundary
i hope this has provided you with an
overview to our approach to identifying
built up area boundaries
throughout the district you can find out
more in the site allocations plan and
submit any comments you have by visiting
our website at www.stratford.gov
dot uk forward slash zappo